Spencer Ackerman with wired.com here at
the Navy's brand new laboratory for
autonomous systems research one of the
things that they do here in this
facility is test human-robot interaction
ultimately when the Navy wants to bring
in robots too many of its core functions
competencies bring match beyond two
ships and have them do jobs alongside
counterparts the robots are going to
need to know a lot of the things that
make us human like operating on
imperfect information confusing
situations and basically being able to
read us like we were you drawing another
so for instance the Navy's testing out
here how octavia can put out a fire you
think that compartment three is not
under control but it has been contained
there is also an arrow is secondary fire
and compartment 5
some of the other things they're testing
in is 50,000 square foot facility in
Southwest Washington DC are how robots
underwater aerial systems sensor systems
reacting a variety of different
simulated environments so there for
instance is a big rock climbing wall
with three feet of sand for simulating a
Middle Eastern arid environment there's
another one that gets up to 80 degrees
with high humidity for a western Pacific
Southeast Asian environment and so on so
Octavia will eventually with a lot of
her robot friends learn how to sort of
interact everywhere on the world that
the Navy and the rest of the US military
goes